i'm sure you and i are the same way like
i have no problem going into an audition
and being rejected right not getting it
based on sometimes whatever i mean it
happens to all of us right we go in we
give our best we're not the guy maybe
it's a look maybe it's our read maybe
it's the casting director the producer
is having a bad day whatever it is but
the one thing that i would think
hurts the most is being fired off of
something getting something being on a
set being around your peers and then
going yeah you know what this isn't what
we wanted and then being fired have you
been fired have you been fired
uh
the only one that i remember being fired
for was a commercial i believe it was
for like whammo or something like that
and i got fired off the commercial my my
consolation prize was like a box full of
toys
but uh you'll like this um i was
replaced by paul walker
who at the time like paul and i would
were the two blondes
in the uh in the industry at that time
you know we were probably eight or nine
at the time and we were the
the guys that would do all the
commercials if you needed a blonde kid
was either paul walker mark paul
wow
you know i remember i remember getting
fired
uh it was only the one time i got fired
but they they made me the offer it was
uh a will farrell and uh mckay
show oh
big top show and they just made me an
offer and i had a meeting and they made
me an offer and i went in and the whole
time they're like you're killing it
we're watching dailies the director's
coming up to me every day oh my god
you're killing it you're killing it
you're killing it we ended up having a
screening at my house at the show with
the cast and everybody and then two
weeks later
they called me the producer in tears and
said
well the good news is i mean they want
to pick us up for five episodes but we
have to let you go they want to replace
your character they think your
character's too dark and says the wrong
[ __ ] and
and i was like what we just screened
this at my house and
every day you're telling me how great i
am and it just shows you how it all is
[ __ ] you just
you never know when it's gonna happen
and i was just like holy [ __ ] they just
let me go i've never been let go and it
just
it is crushing but then i remember
sitting in my office and kind of looking
outside going all right you're alive
breathe breathe you got a dog here i
love your dog you love your dog you got
a house you're lucky to be here i
started to you know these affirmations
you reaffirming that you know hey you
know you're okay you're gonna be okay
but it was it was it was tough
to be let go especially off like your
heroes
will ferrell
and like you know wow i'm gonna be
really working with will ferrell it's
his show
and look the show never made it to air
uh they never even shot those five
episodes but still that feeling i had
was like here was my chance you know
adam mckay wrote wrote me an email hey
it was nothing you did i'd love to work
with you in the future of course that
never happens how many times do you hear
that besides botchco telling you i want
to work with you and it actually happens
it almost never happened before with you